the reality is love between men and
women is not the same at all you know
men shout out to roller tomassi i'm sure
you guys might have touched on this and
i agree with them 100
men love idealistically women love
opportunistically i understand the fact
that as a man a woman loves you for what
you bring to the table you know what i'm
saying your money your income your
income your status your confidence your
ambition your cleverness there's a whole
bunch of different things that women
look for in a man before they can
actually love and submit and want to be
with him but for men it's like you know
we we love women for real because we
don't have as many requirements you love
women for real that's what you said yeah
men men love women idealistically this
is why breakups hurt men way more that's
why men commit suicide way more when it
comes to suicide so what do you break
down what idealistically means as in
they it's the closest i mean obviously
no love is unconditional unconditional
but it's the it's the closest to it like
when a man loves a woman he loves her
far harder than she loves him back and
so to speak this is why women
overwhelmingly uh you know initiate
divorce and breakups et cetera and why
guys have such a tough time getting over
it because when a man loves a woman he
loves her for real when a woman loves a
man she loves him i think the stat here
is that how he makes her feel stats are
45 of marriages end in divorce and women
initiate 80 of them how many did men
cheat in those relationships doesn't
change the fact that that doesn't change
what is love so what does love mean to
you
what's love
it's a bond between two individuals but
you know we're not gonna sit here and
you know say it's a disney fairy here's
the thing man i'm just going to say it
people might say i'm an whatever
it is what is
men put far more at stake when they love
a woman versus the other way around so
men need to approach it with their eyes
wide open and understand that women love
you for what you bring and how you make
them feel and if men understand that
it's going to be to their benefit the
last thing a guy needs to do is love
women the way that you guys are trying
to go with the disney fairy tale type
narrative because the reality is you you
have
far more risk when you get married and
or deal with a woman than the woman has
with you because with the way the family
courts are set up
it's set up for you to lose if
everything goes out the window you know
we know you know 80 of divorces like you
said before initiated by women 90
alimony paid is paid for men to women we
know women uh you know divorce rate is
extremely high in the west in general so
guys need to understand that when you
are with a woman and that she loves you
she loves you for what you bring to the
table and i think you know even though
that sounds horrible that's just the
reality of the world that we live in you
know women are designed to head to mate
with the strongest male that can provide
them security and if that male can no
longer do that at some point she's going
to look to other men and believe him
being a woman just to add one more layer
you see we talked about the
tinder guy right so for example every
single day is done to men how is it done
divorce so get this right she can play a
part play a game for a period of time
and it's oh you know what i'd like to
just leave because i feel like leaving
and get half his money so we're just
saying for example guys should be aware
of the issues that could come up if they
do leave and just be logical about it in
other words men cannot afford to love
the way you guys are trying to claim
through the disney fairy tale lens
because if they do they're going to be
blinded and not be able to you know
apply their logic they said hey can you
you know put the logic to the side and
just level here's an article that's
dangerous here's an article for you guys
and you weigh in on this basically
here's i said millions of men no longer
want to get married and you can thank
the government for that here's the story
u.s news
the magazine reported that marriages
rates marriage rates have reached an
historic low
in the last year or two and with only
6.5 people out of a thousand
getting married that's the lowest level
in 118
years i'll say that again the lowest
level of marriages in the last 118 years
there have been a rise in men's rights
groups we've heard a female i've never
heard of this in my life men's rights
groups you guys probably know about this
such as men going on their own way mg
toe from mgtow
i apologize gentlemen
i'll get the verbatim apologize
i apologize all the mgtows out you don't
want that coming out i don't want that i
don't want that smoke and i also the
manosphere yeah where men in droves
complain about what men's unfair
treatment in relationships and family
courts to your point like we discussed
45 percent of a marriage is end of
divorce 80 of women initiate the divorce
here we go men know that they can lose
a lot and it goes down the list money
kids even their freedom sometimes if
they don't pay child support right and
the courts abundantly favor
women
over men
when the division of assets um
alimony child support all that kind of
stuff like that so from a male like dude
this is stuff that i've never
actually i will say i i was married
briefly i had a prenup and i was like oh
no like we're good to go like whatever
happens we're good um but is this
essentially what you guys are saying is
that are you part of this um mgtow
manosphere is this your vibe what is
this i mean you know we're familiar with
that community you know we're we're kind
of in our own lane but uh you know shout
out to the guys in the sphere and you
know the guys in the mgtow community
they acknowledge a lot of uncomfortable
truths and
and those stats that you just mentioned
is why i said a man cannot afford to go
into a relationship with a woman with
the disney fairy tale in mind they have
to be objective and understand that
you're taking a huge risk when you marry
a woman or move her into your place or
whatever it is i agree with that
completely you do i do actually agree
with them i don't think the system is
right at all that uh
oh somebody should get half of what
you've earned
just because you decided you don't want
to be with them anymore i agree 100 i
don't think it's cool no it's not you
like
you made a decision to either raise a
kid or have a career and hire somebody
to raise your kid you knew that unless
the guy was like you're not allowed to
have money like which we they did talk
about that a woman who makes money is
less attractive so i don't know how that
plays into it i did not say that you
said that the woman who's chasing her
dreams or making lots of money has
attributes that are less attractive to
men you did say that yes on a balance of
probabilities a woman that is successful
there's a high likelihood she will have
unattractive traits therefore making her
less attractive but it is not the mere
fact that she makes money that's
unbelievable no no it's a traits that
come from it agreed so it does put us in
a little bit of a precarious situation
here right because we don't want to be
seeming seemingly unattractive by trying
to make money but if we don't make money
then if something happens in the
marriage and then we're divorced and
we're left with a child and no support
so i mean women always say that but
statistically speaking and we know this
from talking with you know that over a
thousand women and you know thousands of
men all across the world men rarely
initiate breakups and or divorce it's
overwhelmingly women that do it again
we're not talking about men who cheat
wait no no hold on i i i think a lot of
times that but a man real quick a man
can cheat on his girl and still love her
that's that's the difference
okay but then is it not her right to say
i don't want to be with you anymore if
you're cheating on me hey i mean that
might suck but right so where's the
initiative coming from it's not the girl
going oh i want to break up if a man
cheats on her she doesn't feel like he's
trustworthy anymore and then once
initiates the breakup but it's the woman
it's more the women who are initiating
it's not it's not infidelity that causes
most breakups it's actually financial
issues it's money it's it's not
yeah like it's yeah it's not typically
cheating so a lot of times break that
down you have any stats or whatever
anything regarding the financial breakup
i mean that is and or non uh um
a reconciled difference yes they
reconcile differences but that and
that's just kind of like the general
catch-all but a lot of times it boils
down to money
you